all righty folks ami horowitz has done
it again this time
he went around new york asking people
who are vaccinated for covet 19
why are you still wearing a mask before
we dive into that insanity i want to
thank our friends over at ring for
sponsoring this video
stay for the break to receive a special
discount alrighty let's take a look
why do you wear a mask outside what's
your where what's your thought on that
um i'm not sure why good news for you
you don't wear a mask anywhere outside
um okay
there you go all right how do you feel
the same
new york man new freaking new york you
know you don't see in florida
this why wear your mask outside
it feels weird not to
i just like it i got used to it i don't
mind wearing it
i guess i'm just used to it i guess are
you vaccinated
why are you wearing a mask outside
what's your thought process
no comment so first of all
it's not right there half the people
he's talking to not only are they
wearing masks outside after being
vaccinated
the mask is under their nose so even if
they
were like fully covet infected
wearing the mask would do them no good
whatsoever also they're wearing surgical
masks which again aren't like the most
effective
form of man like it's it's such theater
it's such theater yeah i guess like my
friends wear them so i'm like if i'm
social pressure i feel like i won't take
off my mask
until everybody does okay stop it right
there yes this
is exactly the point it's all social
pressure now
there are times when social pressure is
useful like let's say early on the
pandemic we don't know much about this
thing
and there are people who are still going
indoors to places and they're
in those places for long periods of time
and so everybody sort of masks up and
there's social pressure to do so because
you don't want to get funny looks
get it but here's the reality you should
have been wearing a mask when you needed
to wear a mask and not wearing a mask
when you don't i know a lot of people
who still do this by the way who are
still like i don't want to look like a
jerk so i still wear like what if people
look at me funny
well then you tell them i'm vaccinated
leave me alone the fact that we
as a society have become so addicted to
what other people think about us that
we're not willing to do like the most
basic thing like
uncover your face when you are fully
healthy is insane to me
role modeling right i mean it's just
there's a lot of anxieties with taking
the mask off you know
for the first time so it's probably been
so long yeah it's like a social anxiety
at this point i personally still
wouldn't want to take the risk anyway
and i don't trust anyone else so
i'm just doing it for my even if the
science said it was like basically
impossible
still doesn't matter yeah extra
precaution
because i want to protect others and
there's still risk no matter what
so see this is really unhealthy it's
really really unhealthy everybody
has been trained over the past year to
see all other human beings around them
as a potential risk
so much so that even though they are not
a risk anymore it doesn't matter
people are still so addicted to the idea
that everybody around them is a health
threat to them that they're like
there's no limiting principle here you
could literally tell these people to
wear a mask
every day the rest of their life forever
and presumably they'll do it
we'll get to more with ami horowitz in
just one second first let me remind you
it's hard to keep an eye on your house
all day you're not home
all day and there are a thousand reasons
why you want to keep an eye on your home
for me i got three kids seven
five one they're all over the place i
need to keep an eye on them
this is why i rely on ring because if
something is going on
indoors outdoors ring will let me know
it's peace of mind anytime knowing
our home is protected to get ring alarm
for yourself head on over to ring.com
forward slash ben
the perfect way to start your ring
experience you can see it all in one
simple app directly from your phone you
can keep track of whatever is going on
at your house it's great to know you're
not going to miss a visitor with rings
hassle-free
easy to install indoor and outdoor camps
and you'll know when packages are
delivered friends stops by or your kids
are just going
nuts my wife and i moved from california
to florida literally first thing my wife
said get the ring devices
on the house and thus we did start
protecting your home today with ring
alarm
go to ring.com and get your ring alarm
security kit today you can build the
system that's right for your home
have it up and running in minutes that's
ring.com once more ring dot com
slash ben so the science says this is
virtually impossible
to get the chronovisor vaccinated or
spread it while you're outside
sure does that change your thought at
all i know that
but it also sets an example for a visual
example
that's how i feel sometimes i just want
to put it on it because you almost feel
like that like almost a compulsion to do
it because we've been doing for so long
yeah
exactly that's exactly the right thing
to say it's like a pacifier
it's very interesting it has this
passage sure you want to take it yep
security blanket
that's right that's right these people
are using it honestly there are a few
reasons why people wear masks one
it's the security blanket feel people
will leave me alone and it'll keep me
safe even though i'm already safe
and then there's the sort of cultish
aspect of it which is i am great and
virtuous because i'm signaling to others
how virtuous i am
by wearing this mask then there's the
peer pressure oh maybe people will just
leave me alone and like
but here's the reality folks you're an
individual human being
use your brain it's between your ears
try it it's also a little bit of a
protest
the protest being like being well i
shouldn't be
given the privilege to not wear a mask
not only have i been double vacuumed
okay i got to stop it there that one's
hilarious it's a protest against the
privilege of
not being forced to wear a mask when you
see everything in terms of privilege
you're just
it's ghost hunting it's like i whatever
i'm doing today it doesn't matter what
i'm doing
took a dump in the woods it was a
protest man like what was it a protest
against
against people who are privileged by
having toilets
we should all have solidarity with
people have to take a dump in the woods
you can do this with literally any human
action
i woke up this morning i set my car on
fire well that didn't make any sense why
would you do that well
it was a protest against what well you
know the privilege of having cars you
know many people don't have cars
you want to live your life this way man
go for it not only have i been double
vaccinated i had coveted
so you're triple i'm triple so why so
what do you why do you think
you're doing it i think i think it's
virtually impossible to get coronavirus
outside while you're vacuuming oh oh
yeah yeah yeah um i think it's because
um i have been so infuriated people who
didn't wear a mask
when the whole year so it's like a
display of
i still care like my roommate this year
was gonna be from
singapore before everything changed and
uh i would just see videos on his
instagram
like going out clubbing and stuff just
because it was safe over there and it
was kind of like oh man like if we could
actually handle this well
be able to like do stuff but i'm just
stuck inside we handled it better we
could be doing x and everybody else
yeah exactly let's take them off come on
take them off come on
you do succumb to peer pressure jeez
well there you have it people wearing
masks for
no reason and all it took was zombie
just pushing people a little bit
and they took off the mask so let's be
real about this folks if you're
vaccinated
it's time to take off the mask and get
on with your life
because anything else is just you being
an idiot you stupid
all of this is very disquieting there's
this whole theory about human
action that we act in ways we don't
properly understand and then we sort of
make up excuses post-facto for why we do
what we do this video seems to be pretty
good evidence of that that's pretty
scary because if we can be manipulated
into doing things as stupid as wearing
masks outside
post vaccination and we can do that for
a long time
and we can do it because we're virtue
signaling or because we're uncomfortable
with that
what exactly can people with power and
access to information and and authority
what else can they make us do it is
creepy as all hell
so how about this how about you use your
brain how about use your individual
reason
and instead of following all of the
edict
of the experts like sheep actually
analyze the available evidence on your
own
and use the reason god gave you to come
to the conclusion that there is no
reason in hell
why post-vaccination you should be
wearing a mask